bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur figaro la une ce mercredi 5 mai 2021
nous allons vous faire vivre en direct
les cérémonies du bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon 1er
nous devrions assister à un discours du
président de la république emmanuel
macron sous la coupole de l'institut de
france à 17 heures donc dans quelques
minutes le chef de l'état se rendra
ensuite aux invalides pour déposer une
gerbe au pied du tombeau de l'empereur
et notre envoyé spécial thibault il
aurait sera présent sur place justement
aux invalides nous serons avec lui dans
dans quelques minutes qui nous racontera
ce qui s'y passe pour commenter et
analyser cet événement j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés jean brad à géo
pierre brada pardon pierre brand ah
pardon excusez moi c'est l'émotion
historia et membre de la fondation
napoléon
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà lui poser vos
questions et poster vos commentaires sur
le chat du figaro et sur le conte figaro
live de youtube
on attend vous attend et on est là pour
ça donc n'hésitez pas à nous faire part
de vos commentaires je vois que vous
êtes déjà très nombreux d'ailleurs sur
youtube à a montré un peu votre
impatience puisque on a pris ce direct
avec quelques petites minutes de retard
donc on attend vos questions et pierre
gronda se fera un plaisir de vous
répondre qu'un branda le chef de l'état
je lisais se rendra dans quelques
minutes
il y est déjà même d'ailleurs je crois à
l'institut de france il va prendre la
parole sous la coupole de l'institut de
france
quel sens ça a le choix de ce lieu
aujourd'hui ou en commémorant le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
pourquoi n'at-il pas pris la parole aux
invalides
il a pris il prend la parole à
l'institut parce que dans la noble
assemblée je pense qu'il veut dégager
une image un discours fondé sur le
napoléon institutionnel est à prendre
très - toutes les académies qui avait
qu'il avait invité aussi il répond à une
invitation de l'académie et du
chancelier darcos
mais je pense que voilà pour un discours
encore plus solennel peut-être moins lié
à l'image seulement militaire de
napoléon qu'offrirait les invalides
il est dans un cadre voilà plus civil et
d'avant que que forment l'institut et
ses cinq académies je pense que la
raison hélas il y a nicolas sur youtube
qui nous dit pensez vous que macro se
projette et s'identifie à napoléon alors
il écoutait tous les hommes politiques
s'interrogent sur napoléon parce que
c'est une formidable réussite une épopée
une postérité qu'il est qui les séduit
vous aimerait tous avoir la même
postérité et donc il s'interroge alors
est ce qui se compare aux et s'identifie
c'est difficile s'ils le font c'est
quand même dangereux pour eux parce que
tous ceux qui ont voulu s'identifier à
napoléon sont devenus fous donc je ne
l'espère pas pour le président de la
république et pour nous parce qu'il est
quand même le chef de notre état donc je
ne souhaite pas mais bon c'est vrai
qu'ils peuvent vouloir chercher des
inspirations il n'est pas rare que des
conseillers des ministres questions les
historiens sur les méthodes de napoléon
ces méthodes de gouvernement parce que
lui j'ai la france sans twitter sont les
mains il s'en est sans tous nos outils
modernes et pourtant il avait déjà 40
millions de français
france beaucoup plus grande et il a
touché tous les domaines très rapidement
alors pierre brand a je le disais nous
sommes grâce à notre envoyé spécial pour
l'instant avant l'intervention à
l'institut de france
nous sommes en direct avec thibault il
aurait sur les invalides
thibault alors est-ce que vous vous
m'entendez en tout cas je vous entends
et ya l'air d'avoir beaucoup
d'atmosphère sur place alors oui il ya
en effet beaucoup beaucoup d'ambiance il
faut dire qu'ici malgré le froid il fait
environ 13 degrés et les quelques
gouttes de pluie qui me tombe dessus
l'hôpital heures et bien environ 100 à
150 personnes se sont rassemblées ici
aujourd'hui juste et bien devant la
place vauban vous le voyez derrière les
invalides et le tombeau de napoléon on
doit avoir lieu une grande partie de la
cérémonie en présence du président de la
république et de nombreux représentants
et donc eh bien vous le voyez derrière
moi beaucoup d'ambiance je vais essayer
de vous faire vivre de l'intérieur un
petit peu dans quelques minutes
ce qui se passe pour vous puissiez
entendre un petit peu les gens qui sont
entonnés mais pour vous donner un bien
un reflet de la situation et bien ce
sont surtout des associations étudiantes
qui sont présentes derrière moi vous le
voyez peut-être derrière moi mais ce
sont beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes en
grande grande grande majorité de cette
centaine de personnes rassemblées
il y avait tout à l'heure un groupe de
personnes un peu plus âgé avec notamment
des vétérans qui était présent mais qui
vient de partir ont sûrement dû au
mauvais temps et donc et bien depuis
tout à l'heure
et bien c'est une atmosphère très
nationaliste il faut le dire avec
beaucoup de chants nationalistes
patriotique mais surtout militaire on a
pu entendre le chant des africains de
1941 n'a pu entendre également verdun on
ne passe pas qui date de 2002 1916 et
donc et bien toutes ces chants
militaires qui sont là aussi pour
montrer la présence aujourd'hui d'une
institution celle de l'armée
on retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
nous faire vivre une nouvelle fois ce
qui se passe sur l'esplanade en tout cas
en face des invalides place vauban
là où se déroulera tout à l'heure la
pose et la dépose de la gerbe par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron après son intervention à
l'institut de france qui devrait débuter
d'ici un quart d'heure en direct on en
parle tout à l'heure pierre brand à nous
avons des questions qui arrive sur les
tchats du figaro.fr et celui de youtube
il y avait je vais essayer de la
retrouver je crois que c'était nicolas
et qui nous demandait alors je la
retrouve
voilà c'est ariane jo chikhi demande si
napoléon n'avait pas souhaité avant
l'heure une union européenne alors il
avait souhaité une union européenne mais
avec de la prépondérance française donc
c'était un grand empire français avec
des états un peu satellite est donc une
disait toujours la france avant tout
donc c'est pas l'union européenne comme
on la voit aujourd'hui c'est une europe
européenne qui aurait été bleu blanc
rouge quasiment d'un bout à l'autre du
continent donc oui à une volonté
d'unification
néanmoins on a quand même réussi si je
puis dire exporter notre code civil
notamment et l'idée d'égalité s'est
répandu en europe alors peut-être à
certains moments un petit peu trop tôt
parce que les autres pays ont connu le
régime napoléonien sans passer par la
case de la révolution ce qui fait que
l'on ment quand cet épisode quand même
très important les qui expliquait la
suite
eh bien les peuples européens ont été si
je puis dire un peu pris de court
surpris et que pour les réformes mais
n'en voyait pas toujours l'utilité même
si on entrer dans la modernité mais
voilà pour eux c'était une telle passage
tel changement de civilisation qu'une
on pas toujours compris bon il s'est
rajouté évidemment la guerre tout cela
alors alors que j'entends dans mon
oreillette les hourras de la foule qui
s'est massée place vauban en face des
invalides en attendant l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron dans une petite heure
on voit à l'image effectivement des gens
costumés pierre brand ah oui ce sont des
reconstituteurs c'est ça alors là
exactement passé les reconstituteurs
font un travail de historique très très
précis jusqu'au moindre bouton de guêtre
est donc là on a plutôt des gens voilà
qui se sont déguisés pour l'occasion je
dirais surtout ceux voilà ce que tu n'as
rien
lier la garde impériale dans sa tenue
réglementaire et voilà qui comme ça
manifeste son amour pour napoléon mais
cet engouement pour napoléon peut
prendre toutes les formes un peu être un
peu outrancier un peu plus compassé ans
la fondation napoléon nous rencontrons
différents profils de napoli rien et on
se rend compte qu'il n'ya pas une
catégorie de gens bien précises en fait
il ya tout un ensemble de personnes des
militaires mais aussi des étudiants des
beaucoup d'étrangers on n'a pas comme ça
un profil type du napoléonien et ça
ressemble bien d'ailleurs ce qui était
la division en nettoyant à l'époque en
réalité thibault il aurait évoqué deux
sur place à côté de ce monsieur en
costume qui est un admirateur
invisiblement de l'empereur est ce que
vous avez moyen de de prendre sa parole
ne sais pas pourquoi il est là c'est
parce que je crois vous poser quelques
questions je suis sûre internationaux
figurent super merci
est ce que vous pourriez m'expliquer là
la raison de votre présence ici
aujourd'hui et pour tous les espoirs
qu'il a fait
on ya passé bataille est allé
construction il ya les pauses elle est
grande bâtisse et à tous ces grands
monuments que c'est grâce à lui que la
france il en pleurant dribble alors bien
équipés aujourd'hui vous avez une
traditionnelle est même venu accompagné
du canon pour pouvoir juste à côté les
actes vous êtes en temps normal manque
une association c'est une passion non
non c'est personnel s'est fait tout seul
et c'est moi qui a une passion pour lui
mais une vraie passion c'est pas même
façon et même si on touche au drapeau
vrai méchant quoi mais c'est quand même
une liée qui est une passion qui est
très liée à la nation elle même
voilà c'est ça la france c'est pour ça
partout où je vais quand les gens nous
voient ils dit je représente la france
voilà merci beaucoup de demeurer à
monsieur charles vous voyez c'est cette
figure napoléonienne
non sans être un personnage historique
important est toujours aussi un signe de
rassemblement accord aujourd'hui
extrêmement importants sur les plans
bien nationaliste et patriotique
si vous nous rejoignez en direct sur
figaro l'avait sur youtube nous sommes
en train de vous faire vivre en direct
les cérémonies en hommage au bilan les
cérémonies qui célèbre le bicentenaire
de la mort de napoléon
1 une intervention des manuels macron
est attendue sous la coupole de
l'institut de france à 17 heures et puis
il partira ensuite vers les invalides
pour un dépôt de gerbe et ce sera plutôt
d'ici une heure environ et nous serons
également en direct à ce moment là pour
vous faire vivre cet événement cet
événement vous est d'ores et déjà très
nombreux à nous faire part de vos
commentaires
je suis à mes côtés avec pierre brand a
qui est historien et membre de la
fondation napoléon qui est là pour
répondre à vos questions et vos
commentaires j'avais relevé le
commentaire de sébastien rioux merci de
nous partager vos interrogations
sébastien vous vous interrogez sur
youtube sur le côté despotique de
napoléon en demandant si c'était bien
mesuré de le qualifier de despotes
alors ça dépend effectivement de l'
exception faite de la définition auxois
tirant des spots et sert à nous nous
avons maintenant plutôt une définition
liés au 20e siècle
napoléon son exemple c'était césar et
donc il ne se projette et évidemment pas
dans le xxème siècle donc c'est plutôt
et il a voulu copier l'empiré romain un
dictateur à la romaine en fait donc on
est plutôt dans une imitation de la
romantique et qui comme ça
à condition beaucoup de choses et aussi
bien entendu à la suite des monarchies
française donc on est il ne faut pas
voir là se mettre dans l'ain chronic'art
mais je vois que le président s'exprime
non on va laisser parler la pression de
napoléon bonaparte
depuis l'institut de france ont les clés
parce que dire son nom continue de faire
vibrer partout mille cordes d'imaginaire
les canonnades de la campagne d'italie
l'entrechoquement des sabres
d'austerlitz
les suppliques grelottante des soldats
de la grande armée engagée dans la
campagne de russie
napoléon bonaparte est une part de nous
parce que l'action et les leçons du
guerrier du stratège du législateur
autant que du bâtisseur porte encore
c'est ce qu'a notre siècle
il l'est car à mesure que son mythe
s'est construit il devint cette part de
france qui a conquis le monde
chateaubriand on vous avait rappelé l'un
et l'autre la relation tumultueuse avec
l'empereur a saisi en quelque sorte dans
ces termes qui résonne encore
aujourd'hui ce paradoxe vivant il a
manqué le monde
mort il le possède vous êtes lycéen
lycéenne et l'institution même du lycée
la forme d'université nous connaissons
parfois la grande école que vous
rejoindrez dans les mois ou les années à
venir nous en devons quelque chose à
napoléon et pour venir ici à l'institut
de france vous avez traversé paris est
sans doute êtes vous passé devant l'arc
de triomphe l'église de la madeleine la
colonne vendôme peut être avez vous
traversé le pont d'austerlitz ou d'iéna
parcouru la rue de rivoli ses
chefs-d'oeuvre d'architecturé
d'urbanisme toutes ces références nous
les devons aussi à napoléon
c'est là le pont d'austerlitz ou d'iéna
parcouru la rue de rivoli ses
chefs-d'oeuvre d'architecturé
d'urbanisme toutes ces références nous
les devons aussi à napoléon c'est la
vivent et bien peu de destin il faut le
dire ont façonné autant de vie au delà
de la leur c'est ce qui fait que nous
sommes rassemblés ce jour non pas pour
nous livrer à une célébration exalté
comme le site en 1840 le peuple de paris
au retour des cendres de l'empereur mais
pour une commémoration éclairé pour
regarder notre histoire en face et en
bloc
dire comme nation ce que napoléon dit de
nous et ce que nous avons fait de lui
napoléon en 1802 vous l'avez là aussi
évoqué a rétabli l'esclavagé que la
convention de 1794 avait aboli en 1848
avec victor schoelcher la deuxième
république à réparer cette faute
cette trahison de l'esprit des lumières
elle a honoré au panthéon ceux qui comme
toussaint louverture où l'abbé grégoire
hors paire alors le flambeau de
l'universel napoléon
dans ses conquêtes ne s'est jamais
véritablement préoccuper des pertes
humaines
chateaubriand ira jusqu'à l'accuser
d'avoir sacrifié avec force exagération
il faut bien le dire 5 millions de
français
goya immortalisa le massacre cruel de
civils espagnols en 1808
nous avons ensuite depuis lors place et
la valeur de la vie humaine plus haut
que tout que ce soit dans les guerres ou
dans les pandémies napoléon ainsi fidèle
à l'esprit de 1789 à graver dans le
marbre
l'égalité civile entre les hommes dans
le code civil la protection de la loi
pour tous avec le code pénal
nous avons poursuivi cette oeuvre de
progrès en agissant pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et en retirant
du code pénal le plus cruel des
châtiments la peine de mort comme nous
avons aussi élargi le chemin de mérite
tracé avec le baccalauréat en ouvrant
progressivement notre système éducatif
au plus grand nombre au fond de lempire
nous avons renoncé au pire et de
l'empereur nous avons un bel hymne
meilleur commémorer ce bicentenaire
c'est dire cela simplement sereinement
sans céder jamais à la tentation du
procès anachronique qui consisterait à
juger le passé avec les lois du présent
mais en retraçant ce que nous sommes
nous français une société historique un
pays de temps long qui avance sans
effacer sans nier ni renier mais en
réinterprétant sans cesse en
reconnaissant en cherchant à comprendre
une nation panams est qui reçoit les
héritages son testament en peuples
libres 1 de clovis au comité de salut
public
j'assume tout liz est il lui même
aujourd'hui encore nous assumons tous
mais la vie et l'oeuvre de napoléon ne
valent pas seulement pour ce que nous en
avons fait en tant que nation
si sa portée sans frontières si son
éclat résiste à l'érosion des années
c'est parce que charriant l'universel sa
vie porte en quelque sorte en en chacun
de nous comme un écho intimes fait de
vertus anciennes et de paradoxe si
contemporain la vie de napoléon est
d'abord une ode à la volonté politique à
ceux qui jugeaient destin figé les
existences écrite à l'avance le parcours
de l'enfant d'ajaccio devenu maître de
l'europe démontre clairement qu'un homme
peut changer le cours de l'histoire
supprimer ses choix son génie militaire
son énergie
ces options tactiques à toulon sterlite
friedland ou wagram le visage du monde
d'hier comme celui d'aujourd'hui en août
et échanger imaginez réussi les
tentatives d'assassinât de la rue
saint-denis 16 ou deviennent le destin
de la france n'aurait pas été le même
on aime la peau les os parce que sa vie
a le goût du possible parce qu'elle est
une invitation à prendre son risque à
faire confiance à l'imagination à être
pleinement soit la vie de napoléon est
aussi un champ de la raison sans doute
est en effet l'un de ceux qui poussent à
le plus loin en pratique l'héritage des
lumières la confiance en la science
l'art de l'organisation et tout cet
héritage du xviiie siècle dans le
mémorial sainte-hélène sont décrits de
ces dispositions
hors norme en mathématiques les traités
d'arithmétique et de physique dévorer
les jours et les nuits passées sur des
ouvrages de stratégie militaire
gaspard gourgaud un autre de ses
compagnons d'exil dira même de
l'empereur qu'il était un système de
spinoza mais au delà de sa construction
personnelle
napoléon voulu que la raison la science
la technique puisque irriguer le pays
dans son entier pour l'emmener sur le
chemin du progrès ce fut ainsi la
réforme de l'école polytechnique qui
donna et donne encore à la france des
générations d'ingénieurs au plus haut
niveau
ce fut pour l'art militaire saint cyr
qui forma et forment toujours des
officiers de génie napoléon
vous lui aussi à chaque fois lui même
contribué à la progression du savoir
scientifique et de la recherche
la campagne d'égypte pour ne citer qu'un
exemple
plus encore qu'une entreprise militaire
de conquête fut une expédition
scientifique
depuis l'institut où il se montrait
assis du napoléon convainquit plus de
150 mathématicien chimiste géomètre
architectes médecins botaniste parmi les
plus en vue de son temps de rejoindre
une commission des sciences et des arts
qui eut la charge d'étudier la
civilisation la faune la flore les
techniques d'administration de l'egypte
ils le firent et ramenés à une somme de
connaissances salué de tous sa vie enfin
est une épiphanie de la liberté
malgré tous ces paradoxes et tout ce que
vous avez parfaitement restituée de son
rapport à celle ci quand il s'agit de la
liberté des autres
mais si napoléon est le premier des
romantiques ce n'est pas seulement parce
qu'il fascine à goethe
lors de leur rencontre à erfurt parce
que stendhal l'adoré parce que hugo
n'est pas assez d'alexandrins pour le
célébrer ou parce que antoine jean
groleau béni au pont d'arcole visage
émacié cheveux au vent dans cet
arrangement avec l'histoire que vous
évoquez à l'instant non mais parce qu'à
chaque instant et en tout aspect il
réinvente à son existence et fûtes
infiniment libre une force qui va ainsi
de ses amours
qu'il mena toujours selon son coeur et
jusqu'à divorcer après avoir été
couronné par le pape d'avoir noué le
concordat ainsi de son génie militaire
fait d'une grande maîtrise des
stratégies autant que d'un art du
mouvement et de la surprise d'un écart
avec les schémas classiques qui lui
permirent d'atteindre des sommets
ainsi du panache des 100 jours et de ces
kremer inouïe ainsi aussi de ses
faiblesses de la mélancolie de sainte
hélène ainsi de ces contradictions
individualiste rassembleur lucide
inconscient despote éclairé napoléon
cela était écrit était capable de
hauteur ubuesque de modestie provocante
de réussite de rêve comme de ces chutes
qui l'accompagnent règles et ogre
alexandre et n'iront incarnation de la
liberté autant que de la répression
policière
il pouvait en effet être à la fois l'âme
du monde décrit parts égales à iéna et
le démon de l'europe revers funeste de
sa liberté sans limite
ce que napoléon représente dans la
construction de la nation ce que
napoléon charrie d'universel et là et de
là où je suis enfin napoléon est l'homme
qui a donné corps à notre organisation
politique et administrative qui a donné
forme à cette souveraineté dato nantes
qui sortait de la révolution là encore
nulle volonté de juger des conditions
d'accès au pouvoir
18 brumaire et l'orangerie du parc de
saint cloud nulle volonté non plus de
dire si napoléon à concrétiser ou au
contraire des voiliers les valeurs
révolutionnaires je me garderai bien de
m'aventurer sur ses terres d'abord
devant beaucoup plus experts que moi et
parce que ce débat divise à les
historiens dès l'instant où il rendit
son dernier souffle et les agitent
encore aujourd'hui non et le fait est
qu'après des mois des chèques de france
a siégé de violence latente napoléon sud
incarné l'ordre le fait est qu'après des
mois de tâtonnements et d'hésitation il
sut donner une forme durable à la
géniale à la géniale intuition
révolutionnaire de souveraineté
nationale
comment napoléon compris très vite la
nécessité de répondre aux vertiges de la
fin du droit divin en le substituant par
une autre légitimité une autre
transcendance ce fut pour lui le peuple
français
tout ce qui est fait sans le peuple
est il légitime est derrière le peuple
français
ainsi déclaré ainsi installé comme
nouveau foyer d'une souveraineté
nationale d'une transcendance ainsi
trouvé il y avait évidemment pas les
libertés démocratiques
il y avait tout de suite encore la forme
de l'état l'état au travers entre autres
des préfets des mères qui se déployèrent
bientôt partout dans le pays
permira la nation de rester une l'état à
travers les grandes institutions mises
en place alors napoléon compris aussi
qu'il devait rechercher sans cesse
l'unité et la grandeur du pays
il le fit par la guerre en trouvant à la
france des ennemis communs comme
l'angleterre en répondant aussi à la
soif française d'universel par une
projection du modèle révolutionnaire à
l'échelle de l'europe
il le fit en apaisant les relations avec
les grandes religions par le concordat
grand sanhédrin il le fit par les arts
il le fit en veillant réconcilier aussi
ce que la révolution avait opposé dans
le sang et s'il ne renonça jamais au
principe de mérite et d'égalité d'accès
aux charges napoléon fut ainsi l'artisan
de l'aministie d'une partie des
royalistes d'une unité incarner jusque
dans son gouvernement
au fond l'acteur résolue d'une synthèse
nationale concrétiser jusque dans les
symboles utilisés lors de son sacre la
main de justice
les abeilles mérovingienne le collier de
l'ordre de la légion d'honneur
car son ultime intuition fut de vouloir
combler le vide laissé par la figure du
roi le 21 janvier la solution de celui
qui devint en 1802 conçu la vie fut
radical confié dans un oxymore
extraordinaire la république à un empire
en devenant empereur des français
ambitions personnelles assurément façon
de prévenir toute tentation de retour à
l'état antérieur et d'ancrer la
révolution dans la durée certainement
les français en 1789
on fait écrit tocqueville le plus gros
effort auquel se soit jamais livré aucun
peuple coupée en deux leurs destinées se
séparer par un abîme de ce qu'ils
avaient été jusque-là de ce qu'il
voulait être désormais le génie de
napoléon fut d'aider les français à
rompre définitivement avec ce qu'ils
avaient décidé d'abandonner en 1789 et
de franchir cet avis il ne pouvait
cependant tout à la fois ancré la
révolution et interdire aux français le
goût de la liberté dont elle était
porteuse en cela 1789 fut plus fort que
napoléon vous êtes lycéen comme français
vous vous inscrivez dans cette histoire
vous n'en n'êtes ni les responsables ni
les gardiens vous pouvez les mais comme
la critiquer encore faut-il la prendre
la connaître mais elle est là elle vous
construit viatique pour affronter ce
siècle
elle fait partie de vous et vous avez à
la continuer alors sans doute l'oeuvre
total de napoléon tout en clair obscur
n'at-elle pas livré encore tous ses
secrets
mais incontestablement elle continue de
nous forger et le soleil d'austerlitz
brille encore vive la république vive la
france
[Applaudissements]
si vous venez de rejoindre en direct sur
figaro la vie sur youtube on vient
d'assister à la prise de parole du chef
de l'état emmanuel macron qui
intervenaient sous la coupole de
l'institut de france en ces
commémorations du bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon 1er
je suis avec pierre brand à historien
membre de la fondation napoléon qui est
là pour répondre à toutes vos questions
vos interrogations et vos commentaires
que vous pouvez livrer sur le chat du
figaro et sur youtube et parmi ces
interrogations d'abord à pierre mandat
je vais demander ce qu'il a pensé du
discours de cette intervention attendue
du chef de l'état bah écoutez le soleil
doit sa vie ce brillant corse et sa
conclusion emmanuel macron a pris un
risque
la célébrer nos moyens car
nous devons dire que nous n'aurions pas
pu dire finalement mieux en disant que
napoléon fait partie de mou et j'ai
entendu qu'il a dit il est en nous et
c'est une part de nous que c'est notre
histoire que nous continuons qu'on peut
critiquer ce qui nous ce qui est aussi
notre cas comme historien est en tout
cas qu'il faut continuer et qu'il a
démontré que napoléon ans a fondé les
bases de la france moderne et bien
entendu tout n'a pas été parfait il l'a
rappelé mais voilà cette histoire là
c'est la nôtre elle continue d'être la
nôtre et en cela il avait il a bien
raison ce discours est très est beaucoup
plus fort que celui de georges pompidou
en 1969 qui avait commenté la destinée
de napoléon et qui avait insisté sur
l'union des français mais georges
pompidou n'avait pas été aussi loin
évidemment et à savoir que emmanuel
macron il est seulement le deuxième
président de la république s'est exprimé
sur napoléon et puisqu'après georges
pompidou il n'y a plus une intervention
non il n'y en avait pas eu avant
c'est à dire que en 1921 pour le
centenaire de la mort de napoléon le
président d'alors bien oublié mille rang
de la troisième république ne s'est pas
exprimé c'est foch qui a fait un éloge
plutôt militaire de l'homme n'en n'était
ressortie de la première guerre mondiale
mais c'est dire que finalement le
bicentenaire de napoléon et
l'intervention du chef de l'état marque
une autre étape et finalement une étape
un peu paradoxalement moins critique que
par le passé quand même on l'oubli dans
le discours de georges pompidou mais
georges pompidou avait aussi signalé le
manque de liberté avait signalé un
certain nombre de choses ce n'est pas un
discours aussi à géographique on l'a
prétendu est arrêté à de manière un peu
plus pas comme on l'attendait emmanuel
macron a été plus allégée au graphique
que quenelles et et georges pompidou
vous parliez de controverses un pierre
brand est associée à ces commémorations
d'ailleurs on le voit sur les réseaux
sociaux du figaro que ce soit sur
youtube et sur lefigaro.fr
on les voit ces oppositions trop
effectivement admirateurs partisans de
napoléon et ses opposants
comment on
on explique que cette célébration
aujourd'hui elle suscite autant
controverse
vous citiez georges pompidou et lé chef
de l'état qui se sont qui ont ignoré
napoléon depuis pompidou jusqu'à
emmanuel macron comment on explique
cette controverse et ce refus de
célébrer alors il ya d'appeler on a
toujours déchaîné les patients et
emmanuel macron l'a dit aussi dans un
discours au tout début mais n'a pas
dénoncé aussi à nîmes et surtout un
imaginaire qui a frappé tout le monde
mais qui a pu l'être un imaginaire
positifs comme négatifs il a cité la
russie la cité recolle donc cet
imaginaire là et l'imaginaire de la
france qui c'est qui c'est comme ça
répandu au delà des frontières
évidemment il ya eu des décisions en soi
au rétablissement des esclavages par
exemple qui choque les les mémoires
contemporain évidemment juste titre mais
on ne peut pas résumer l'histoire de
napoléon à ces polémiques qui par
ailleurs change suivant les époques et
même si la décision il l'a regretté
lui-même de rétablissement en esclavage
et était une faute on ne peut pas
réduire l'histoire de napoléon à la
seule où seuls rétablissement des
esclavages comme on ne peut pas réduire
l'histoire de révolution à ses seuls
crimes et on ne peut pas effectivement
il laissé entendre aussi on ne peut pas
résumer l'histoire de la révolution
française à la guillotine donc tout ceci
est plus complexe que ce qu'il a dit
effectivement c'est que voilà que ce
soit la révolution française comme
napoléon
ça fait partie de nous et finalement
rejeté ces deux histoires enfin qu'ils
sont qui sont continus dans le temps et
bien c'est nous rejeter nous mêmes parce
que ce serait renier notre identité et
céder effectivement à la cancel culture
qui serait une table rase et la table
rase ce comme inconvénient principal
c'est que en partant de rien eh bien on
arrive au pire on y reviendra bien
rendre à cet héritage controversé on va
tous se retrouver thibault iso etc et en
direct depuis les invalides où doit se
rendre dans quelques minutes le chef de
l'état pour faire un dépôt de gerbes au
pied du tombeau
thibault vous m'entendez vous avez je
crois quelqu'un à côté de vous qui qui
étant en mesure de répondre à quelques
questions
exactement on est en direct avec
valentin qui nous vient je crois de nos
ventes expliqué dans la rue alors ma la
raison est très simple c'est les
commémorations du bicentenaire de la
mort de l' empire
voilà très simplement c'est à dire que
moi bon je suis comme en oeuvre
patriotes d'abord et avant tout j'aime
la france est comment dire
bon alors effectivement gm europe
monsieur alors j'aime l'europe
j'aime lempire que j'aime la france et
il me semblait important de commémorer
l'an pire et surtout napoléon bonaparte
parce qu'il a il a fait énormément pour
la france même si la france ne verront
pas aujourd'hui mais j'ai l'impression
que les gens
et si aujourd'hui sur avec d'autres pour
représentation à la france
certaines appartenance
ouais
pour moi personnellement si je peux
paraître je suis énormément passionné
d'histoire c'est à dire que toute liste
en france me touche énormément
mais après si vous voulez que je vous
réponds pour moi la france n'a jamais
été aussi puissant que sous l'empiré à
dire que je l'aurais aimé sa vie
personnelle invention mais j'aurais aimé
vivre sous l' empire et donner ma vie
voilà pourquoi parce que cet homme a
tant donné pour la france il a et a sué
sang et eau par le rire
environ à l'origine
faut dire que c'est un
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire que bon si on voulait il
vient d'une faible noblesse corse qui
m'assurerait et
il arrive à grimper les échelons et il
monte ça mais au sommet de la france et
ensuite au sommet de l'europe c'est à
dire que pour moi c'est un exemple et
pour moi en tant que français c'est un
énorme exemple c'est à dire que napoléon
bonaparte j'ai grandi avec ses récits
père
happart a bien sûr mais quand j'entends
que ces récits je me dis d'accord je
suis français et je suis un héritier de
cela effectivement je n'ai avis charles
oman ont ce genre de choses comme
n'importe qui aujourd'hui en france
mais je le dis ça c'est bien que proche
de jeu souvent plus contemporain de
napoléon bonaparte que n'importe qui je
vous reconnais plus vous voyez en cet
empire qui et c'est comment dire
d'étendre le les valeurs justement qu'on
s'est échiné à combattre pendant cette
première république
bon ce n'est pas lui je suis humaniste
avant tout et voilà
napoléon bonaparte et et humaniste avant
tout ce truc que je crois justement à
l'ambiance aujourd'hui
beaucoup de personnes à ceux qui sentent
le jeune ce que je peux demander votre
situation
alors moi que je croyais je j'ai 24 ans
et je suis né à nancy et j'ai grandi et
alors une dernière question bien dit
tout à l'heure que la france n'est pas
forcément à napoléon qu'elle lui devait
c'est vrai que napoléon avait une figure
encore très décriée qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
cet avis est aujourd'hui moi je voulais
tout simplement
c'est très simple il apollon bonaparte
il voulait la france est telle qu'elle
est grâce à la couleur de la partie
simplement c'est très simple le prenais
mon code civil
vous prenez plein d'autres je connais
plein d'autres institutions françaises
c'est grâce à lui la guerre alors 70%
des 1
attention française et grâce à ses très
simple
c'est à dire que c'est lui qui fait la
transition entre l'ancien régime et la
france moderne et proment mais napoléon
bonaparte
c'est la france rayonnante
voilà c'est le la dernière épopée avant
la france qui s'est à voilà si vous
voulez j'ai napoléon bonaparte 14-18
39-45 mon ces primes payées mais si vous
voulez il ya toujours cet esprit
français et républicains et
nationalistes japon la partie pour avoir
donner votre avis
cette journée du bicentenaire merci
aussi
voilà vous le voyez une longue
intervention les écouter c'est toujours
intéressant d'avoir aussi la vie des
personnes qui viennent se rassembler
avec donc et bien comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure sur tout et bien
cette vision très patriotique d'une
personne d'un personnage historique en
la personne de bonaparte ici devant les
invalides
charlotte ainsi thibault on vous
retrouvera peut-être tout à l'heure
après les dépôts de gerbes au panthéon
auquel on doit au panthéon pardon aux
invalides auquel on doit assister en
présence du chef de l'état dans quelques
minutes pierre brand à vous êtes
historien je le rappelle membres de la
fondation napoléon on entendait ce
monsieur qui intervenait place vauban
devant les invalides pour lui c'était
extrêmement important de commémorer le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
on sait que des pans de l'héritage de
napoléon sont sont présents dans notre
quotidien
aujourd'hui le code civil l'examen du
baccalauréat la banque de france au
conseil d'état ces points positifs sont
plutôt effacé ces dernières heures ces
dernières semaines ces derniers jours on
va dire par la décision de napoléon
d'avoir rétabli l'esclavagé en 1802
alors qu'il avait été aboli une première
fois en 1794
c'est une énorme polémique ces derniers
jours que peut-on dire de cette décision
de napoléon est ce que on peut
considérer que même à l'époque c'était
une faute morale
alors c'est à l'époque ça n'a pas été
dénoncé en façade et dénoncé par
certains très minoritaire en fait hélas
comme une faute morale d'abord il
faudrait d'abord revenir très rapidement
génèse de l'abolition ou remarquer 1789
la révolution 1794 seulement l'abolition
de l'esclavagé cinq ans donc déjà
attendre parce qu'en réalité les
révolutionnaires n'ont fait que
entériné une situation de fait c'est que
les esclaves s'étaient libérés eux-mêmes
et qu'on alors que nous étions en guerre
contre l'angleterre en train de perdre
nos colonies on a préféré armes et les
esclaves plutôt que d'essayer dans les
plantations
quand la guerre avec l'angleterre cesse
si je puis dire le motif principal est
là ce qui avait motivé l'abolition des
esclavages disparaît donc une question
se pose on récupère des colonies on veut
retrouver une france florissante et
hélas la france d'ancien régime était
florissante en grande partie grâce au
commerce du sucre du café et du coton
donc bonaparte
si je puis dire obéir suit met en place
une synthèse avec le laurier choisi
plutôt l'ordre ancien mais c'est hélas
la loi de la majorité
je rappellerai que le président de la
république inciter les figures de
toussaint louverture par exemple mais
toussaint louverture ce général ancien
esclave qui à saint domingue a pris le
contrôle de la colonie a pris aussi le
contrôle de saint domingue partie
espagnole et par exemple n'avait pas
aboli l esclavage dans la partie
espagnole
donc c'est une erreur établi un travail
forcé dans la partie occidentale de
l'île c'est une question complexe
également l'abbé grégoire qui était qui
a fait partie des parlementaires sous l'
empire le chantre de l'abolition après
la décision de napoléon de rétablir
l'esclavagé il est devenu sénateur
d'empyr comte d'empiré a même reçu la
légion d'honneur
donc il ne s'est pas vraiment opposé lui
non plus à cette décision qui hélas
procéder d'une dune louis du fait d'un
contexte à la fois géopolitique et
politique des potes ce qui n'excuse pas
napoléon qu'il a regretté à sainte
hélène il a dit j'ai commis une faute et
j'aurais mieux fait de laisser la
situation existante quand je les
trouvais bon c'est un dossier qu'il
connaissait mal c'est un jeune chef
d'état il a 30 ans ça explique le
contexte mais ça n'excuse pas cette
décision évidemment mes doigts là aussi
nous faire réfléchir et comprendre
pourquoi un homme comme lui qui a priori
était pour l'abolition j'appelle n'a pas
eu et il a libéré des esclaves à malkin
avait été pas il n'a pas écrit le
moindre texte esclavage
n'a pas eu d'éclats comme george
washington par exemple donc je dirai
comment cet homme là on est arrivé à
prendre cette décision s'est confronté à
une situation exceptionnelle qui l'a
prise malheureusement trop vite trop mal
est ce qu'il ya eu des conséquences
évidemment dramatique je préciser que
que l'elysée a fait savoir un
qu'emmanuel macron présidera le 10 mai
une cérémonie à l'occasion de la journée
nationale de mémoire de l'esclavagé
quelques commentaires que vous laissez
sur les réseaux sociaux du figaro en ce
moment celui de qwerty sur lefigaro.fr
elle dit pourquoi célébrer le
bicentenaire aujourd'hui c'est important
mais l'actualité de la crise économique
est bien plus importante qu'est ce que
vous pouvez lui répondra qwerty oui la
crise sanitaire je vous répondrai que et
bien en 1799 la france aussi connaissait
une situation de crise exceptionnelle ne
faut peut-être pas un dit enfin remettre
comme l'appliqué bonaparte mais ce
qu'avait réussi à faire en napoléon et
le président de la république la cité
c'est quand même large union de tous les
français
pour s'en sortir il avait compris bien
avant le général de gaulle que la france
n'était jamais aussi petit que
lorsqu'elle est désunie et en réalité
nous devons sortir de cette crise le
plus unis possible parce que si nous
nous divisons assez largement et bien
nous aurons beaucoup plus de mal parce
que la france à cet handicap de s'abîmer
plus que les autres pays dans la
division et ça c'est un défaut nationale
et qui voit là que napoléon puis de
gaulle ont tenté de corriger mais voilà
qui qui parfois nous comme ça peut-être
difficile que d'être difficile pour la
france si vous nous rejoignez à
l'instant sur figaro l'avait sur youtube
nous sommes en train de vous faire vivre
les commémorations du bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon 1er
avec guy ya quelques minutes déjà la
prise de parole du chef de l'état
emmanuel macron sous la coupole de
l'institut de france il est en train de
se rendre maintenant aux invalides pour
un dépôt de gerbe au pied de la tombe et
du tombeau de napoléon 1er
nous sommes toujours en présence et à
mes côtés de pierre brand à historien et
membre de la fondation napoléon qui est
là pour répondre à vos questions et
elles sont nombreuses
y avait une question intéressante il ya
quelques minutes de raphaël david sur
youtube qui nous demandaient ils
disaient bonjour du québec bonjour
raphaël si vous êtes toujours avec nous
comment est perçue napoléon 1er à
l'international et notamment aux
etats-unis et en amérique
alors il est perçu comme le self made
men fait celui qui effectivement parti
de rien de pas grand chose est arrivée
au sommet et quelle somme a
effectivement être empereur empereur de
l'europe et suivre les pas d'hugh à la
fois d'alexandre de césar donc c'est aux
états unis il est surtout perçue comme
cet homme là même si évidemment dans le
débat actuel américain la question de
l'esclavagé ressurgit ans chez eux une
importance égale ment parce que c'est
cette zone
monde qui avaient été concernés donc du
coup il ya aussi des critiques sur cet
aspect là on est en train de voir
emmanuel macron et son épouse brigitte
mâcon qui sont arrivé aux invalides et
qui vont s'apprêter à y entrer pour ce
dépôt de gerbes au pied du tombeau de
l'empereur au rite accueilli
effectivement par l'armée par la
ministre et les différents chefs
d'états-majors puisque les analyses sont
un site militaire et le dôme des
invalides est devenue une nécropole
nationale car
il ne faut pas oublier que outre
napoléon et il ya les tombeaux de foch
lyautey vauban turenne et des frères
napoléon joseph et gérone donc et
ensuite il ya aussi dans les caveaux les
gouverneurs des invalides défunt est
évidemment et donc c'est une nécropole
nationale nécropole militaire avant tout
le dôme des invalides ce n'est plus une
église l'église de ceux et juste
derrière donc c'est évidemment le site
militaire le site des gloires militaires
de la france et c'est tout à fait normal
que le président de la république soient
accueillis par l'armée lui même étant le
chef des armées
comme vous le savez sans doute en
préparant cette émission près puis
apprend d'âge et j'ai appris un combien
napoléon était attaché à la construction
de son image quitte à parfois réécrire
l'histoire et sa propre histoire et
nombreux de nombreux tableaux nombre de
tableaux leurs représentants dont sont
l'oeuvre de l'entreprise de
communication voire on peut peut-être
dire de propagande 1,2 de napoléon 1er
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
et d'ailleurs ça rebondit je rebondis
par rapport à ce que disait il ya
quelques minutes sur le chat de youtube
jobs virologue de youtube
virgin blog qui nous disait il me semble
que napoléon n'a pas chargé à arcole il
s'agit d'un des mythes qu'il a fondé
alors il a il a tenté une passage au
pont d'arcole ça c'est vrai seulement
devant le feu autrichien il est tombé
dans la rivière son aide de camp
mourants et mort à ses côtés mais
effectivement il ne l'a pas franchi et
si je puis dire son mais quand même il a
bravé le feu napoléon n'avait pas peur
c'est un militaire il n'avait pas peur
de la mort sur le champ de bataille il a
même parfois chercher
va pas exagérément mais pour avoir comme
ça une fin glorieuse parce que ce qui à
l'époque est un une valeur essentielle
c'est la gloire en fait
et donc oui mais mais bien entendu le
tableau magnifique encore plus cet
épisode qui est qui dans la réalité est
beaucoup moins comme ça artistique on va
dire l'empereur on l'a entendu on l'a vu
on voit les admirateurs qui se sont
massés devant les invalides pour cet
hommage aujourd'hui au bicentenaire de
sa mort quand est ce que véritablement
napoléon 1er à aa a construit sa légende
a commencé à écrire sa légende
il a commencé à l'âge de 26 ans lors de
la première campagne d'italie justement
au sort va bataille de l'audi où il a
dit je il a compris qu'il avait changé
de dimension
et quand il va entrer dans mille ans au
sein d'al écrira plus tard quand
bonaparte en tradant milan alexandre et
césar sûr qu'ils avaient un successeur
napoléon est d'abord le conquérant et
celui qui veut imiter ses arrêts
alexandre do l'expédition d'egypte
donc on est comme ça dans l'imitation de
l'antiquité limitation des grands
personnages et napoléon veut être leurs
successeurs je verrai on va on va
peut-être répondre à tristan hamlin qui
nous dit bonjour à vous pourquoi
est-ce-que l'exclavage fut rétabli alors
qu'il l'a abolie à malte quelle est la
vraie raison de cette réinstauration de
l' esclavage qui ne peut être raciste
vous avez déjà répondu il ya une visite
à ce sujet pierre brand a alors sur les
images on voit le prince napoléon
le chef de la maison impériale qui
accueille le président de la république
avec son épouse le
je voulais dire le prince napoléon est
le descendant de jérôme du dernier frère
napoléon les bonaparte la fratrie
bonaparte il était 8 à napoléon et le
second et jérôme le dernier donc c'est
le l'arrière arrière petit fils de
jérôme bonaparte qu'on appelle prince
napoléon qui accueille comme ça le
président de la république comme l'avait
fait son grand père l'avant dernier
prince napoléon lorsque georges pompidou
s'était rendu à ajaccio le 15 août 1969
donc nous avons là une parfaite
continuité dans la séquence du
bicentenaire entamée donc en ce 15 août
1969 et qui se termine aujourd'hui le 5
mai 2021 dans une sorte de parallélisme
des formes si je puis dire et avec une
révision nous n'aurons pas ce qui
s'était passé en 1969 c'est à dire 21
coups de canon tirés au moment alors là
c'était la naissance mais où en 1921 le
moment de la mort mais à part cela on
est quand même dans une cérémonie d'une
certaine ampleur
alors si on a quelques secondes encore
pour pour vous laisser parler pierre
banda on va essayer de répondre à la
prod qui est un internaute sur youtube
qui nous dit et pouvez vous parler des
maréchaux de napoléon ils ont une place
importante dans son succès oui bien sûr
parce que il faut pas voir que seulement
napoléon dans cette époque il n'aurait
rien fait tout seul
donc il a su s'entourer l'a su
s'entourer de
généraux de maréchaux qui ils ont été
26,1 des maréchaux komlan masséna murat
berthier des noms qui résonnent et des
gens qui issu de la révolution était
arrivé à au sommet de la gloire
militaire et qui symbolise toute une
époque parce que bonaparte c'est aussi
le mouvement de la jeunesse le mouvement
d'une d'une génération née dans les
années 1760 9770 qui arrive finalement
très tôt au pouvoir grâce à la
révolution mais ce sont des hommes
jeunes et qui vont effectivement
bouleversé l'europe et napoléon n'est
effectivement pas seul dans ce moment il
est à la tête de ses hommes mais il ya
beaucoup d'hommes derrière lui on voit
le tombeau en ce moment à l'image est ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter un peu ce
qui ce qui constitue le tombeau et et en
quoi cette cette pièce en croire encore
au titre
voilà ça alors ce sarcophage en fête a
été construit et nouvelles en 1861 sous
le second empire à cette crypte
n'existait pas avant l'arrivée de
napoléon a été construite spécialement
pour lui
et dans ce tombeau en quartzite rouge
alors cela cette couleur n'est n'est pas
évidemment est fait exprès c'est la
couleur des tombeaux des empereurs
romains
c'est pour ça que ça a été choisi et
napoléon est arrivé aux invalides par la
décision de louis philippe 1 le roi
louis philippe qui avait voulu ramener
les cendres napoléon de sainte-hélène
puisque d'abord napoléon a été enterré à
sainte hélène le 9 mai 1821 il est resté
19 en wifi souhaite ramener ses cendres
parce que le mouvement autour de lui sa
nostalgie prendre l'ampleur
il souhaite en quelque sorte l'enterrer
véritablement sauf que ça ne marchera
pas en fait le moment bonapartiste va
gagner en importance et ce sera son
neveu le voila voila si de sortie qui
est grand ce qui surprend toujours
d'ailleurs parce que la taille est
vraiment gigantesque surtout ce sont les
cendres alors alors quand on dit les
saint-louis à l'époque c'est son corps
est quand on a ouvert son cercueil quand
on est allé le chercher à sainte-hélène
son corps était relativement intact un
napoléon repose dans cinq cercueils en
acajou de enfers en plomb et de en bois
et donc je veux dire il et c'est pour ça
qu'il a été conservé et c'est un petit
peu momifié naturellement et quand il
est comme ça ensuite enchâssé dans ce
grand sarcophage en porphyre rouge qui
comme ça a été l'oeuvre de l'architecte
visconti qui a qui a comme ça conçu
cette crypte parmi et son projet a été
retenu parmi des centaines de projets et
tout autour vous avez des fresques qui
rappelle l'oeuvre napoléonienne du
conseil d'état les lycées le concordat
et c est au sol vous avez également
mentionné le nom des ses principales
victoires marengo austerlitz wagram et
nous voyons donc le chef de l'état face
à l'imposant sarcophage qu'il avait déjà
visité évidemment auparavant mais de
manière officielle puisque quelques
semaines après son élection il avait
emmené la le président de 30
alors voilà du président de la
république
non je pense ou peu
il s'appelle pas pressé non sans lui
donc dépôt de gerbe
je pense avec des demoiselles de saint
cyr et nous voyons des saint cyriens
puisque saint cyr date de l'époque
napoléonienne
je pense que autant plus un salut aux
morts minute de silence
voilà
la marseille
quatre chanteurs
c'est beau
les heurts entre des road
il
à projets
[Musique]
ça
vva
la syrie
on le voit un petit peu quand même saisi
par le ce temps est assez grave que
quelques minutes c'est plus dur de
réflexion et de comme ça d'un bruit
d'inclination enfin face à napoléon un
sujet ans d'histoire qui ne laisse
évidemment pas indifférent mais il l'a
rappelé qui fait partie de l'histoire il
fait partie surtout de nous français
dans jusque dans notre quotidien ou
l'avez dit c'est effectivement les
lycées etc ce drame mais c'est aussi la
numérotation des rues
c'est le signe roland à droite c'est
napoléon et tant de choses autour de ça
qui sont parfois très comme ça qui font
partie de la vie quotidienne ou qui sont
pas forcément de grandes réformes et
donc beaucoup sur l'unité d'un geste du
président de la république et le fait
qu'il ait voulu être accompagnés et
qu'il est posée une gerbe avec le
représentant de la maison impériale mais
aussi un auto sien c'est un symbole en
soi alors se saisit baj évidemment on ne
va pas l'installation d'une oeuvre d'art
contemporain au dessus du tombeau de
l'empereur qui a suscité depuis quelques
jours également une autre polémique et
la colère des historiens il s'agit je
vais préciser un d'une oeuvre temporaire
du plasticien pascal convert qui ne sera
visible ou pas titre a pas visibles
aujourd'hui on l'a vu elle n'est pas
visible a été décrochée pour pour ce 5
mai elle va être raccrochée
prochainement elle est censée être
visible dès la réouverture d'ailleurs
des des lieux culturels
l'oeuvre s'intitule memento marengo et
en fait c'est un squelette de 35 kg qui
est suspendu par par des filins d'acier
sous le dôme des invalides qu'on voit en
ce moment au dessus de la fosse qu'on
voit également à l'image où se trouve le
tombeau de napoléon 1er est ce squelette
en fait est une réplique du cheval
préféré de l'empereur qui s'appelait
marengo c'est un petit arabe barbe
capturés par les troupes de wellington à
waterloo
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous pierre
brand delà de cette polémique est ce que
vous pensez qu'elle est justifiée ou pas
oui tout à fait c'est un pur scandale je
le rappelais nous sommes dans une
nécropole militaire et 7 heures
strictement rien à y faire d'abord en
plus c'est un scoop que je vous livre
mais la fondation napoléon nous avons
découvert que ce n'est même pas jusque
là de marengo qui se trouve à londres
marengo est un cheval mythique peut-être
pas forcément exister en plus donc je
veux dire c'est une réplique de faux en
réalité ces poutres agents pour the lady
pour les morts on doit quand même un
respect aux morts même si on n'aime pas
napoléon j'ai dit à d'autres personnages
comme emblématique de notre histoire
commencée par le maréchal foch et c'est
donc choquant mais c'est aussi
grotesques
parce que ça se prête à la cléricature
au ridicule et donc n'ont pas besoin de
ça imaginez un étranger qui pénètre dans
le dom des abeilles qui saisit par la
majesté qui voient ce squelette suspendu
il peut soit pensé que bien c'est
halloween avant l'heure ou alors il se
dit tiens spielberg est passée par là il
nous fait jurassic park
voilà je veux dire nous avons des
références aujourd'hui elles valent ce
qu'elles valent mais nous avons des
références dans aussi notre imaginaire
d'aujourd'hui et ce n'est certainement
pas celle de pascal convert qui nous
expliquent les guerriers été enterrés
avec leurs chevaux alors ça n'a jamais
été le cas des armées français ni même
de napoléon qui aurait voulu être à
enterrer avec son cheval c'est ridicule
et on nous explique aussi qu'il
s'agirait de pégase encore propre et
très très bien si on l'en terre aussi
s'envole enfin bon marengo est censé
être aussi dit mémento marengo mémento
mori souviens-toi que tu es mortels bon
napoléon est déjà mort donc je vois pas
ce qu'on lui rappelle donc c'est
absolument ridicule sortie en fait d'une
volonté fait sans concertation et qui va
être très reproché au musée de l'armée
aux invalides et une fille née au
président de la république y risque
après cela cette séquence très digne
d'être abîmés par l'image et une autre
leçon à retenir de napoléon c'est que
justement souvent l'image l'emportent
sur les mots et que donc
il faut il qu'on vienne si vous voulez
prendre une décision en tant que chef
des armées de ne pas raccrocher ce
squelette qui est totalement ridicule
alors pour répondre à l'internaute réel
sur youtube et le chat du figaro qui
demande qui aurait le nom de l'endroit
s'il vous plaît mais on était en direct
depuis la coupole des invalides et vous
êtes en train de le voir en ce moment le
dôme des invalides
je sois général par l'aplomb du oui à
l'aplomb du sarcophage est en fait quand
vous entrez sur hauteur de vue d'un
individu en fait c'est juste voilà à
l'aplomb du rebord de la crypte de qui
sera donc suspendu avec des filins à
partir du don en fait double du plafond
donc il est juste dessus marengo donc
plane comme ça au dessus des squelettes
le faux squelette du faux marengo plane
comme ça au dessus du vrai napoléon donc
ça n'a aucun sens c'est totalement
révoltant l'art contemporain si on peut
l'appeler ainsi n'excuse bateau règle au
connico nous dit napoléon restera le
plus grand homme moderne que ce pays ait
connu la france est éternel et nous
sommes fiers de notre histoire la classe
politique doit arrêter de prêter
attention aux pleureuses
qui étaient les personnes qui marchaient
au côté de napoléon
autour d'eux du tombeau de napoléon
je crois que vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure mais peut-être un peu leur à
pied oui combien de temps vous l'avais
appelé napoléon macro oui donc non mais
c'est tout à fait révélateur c'est parce
que effectivement comme comme il sait si
je puis dire approprié l'histoire
napoléonienne
on peut contacter lapsus non non c'est
vrai c'est le prince napoléon donc le
descendant de jérôme le le frère cadet
de napoléon le dernier de la fratrie des
bonaparte qui meurent en 1860 il
il leur pose aussi à côté de son frère
dans la chapelle saint jérôme justement
et c'est lui qui a été gouverneur des
invalides aussi et qui a accueilli la
dépouille de son frère est comme ça
présidé les travaux de la crypte mais
ces îles et l'arrière arrière petit fils
de ce jérôme bonaparte là et donc chef
de la maison impériale est le descendant
de napoléon évidemment pas la branche de
son frère donc c'est un membre de la
famille impériale a le plus plu aux
membres de la famille impériale son
altesse père le prince napoléon d'aller
son titre compris accordée par la
république qui accueillit emmanuel
macron il a emmené voilà et a déposé la
gerbe avec lui vous disais tout à
l'heure à pierre brand à vous rappeliez
que napoléon est mort à sainte hélène il
est mort à l'âge de 51 ans le 5 mai 1821
loin des siens loin de son pays et que
c'est sa dépouille a été donc rapatrié
on va dire sur le sol français
saint-helens est une île perdue de
l'atlantique sud où les britanniques
avaient envoyé l'empereur en exil après
sa dernière défaite à waterloo
de quoi est mort napoléon alors napoléon
souffrait d'un
une atteinte et reste aux maladies de
l'estomac d'abord en huile certes une
gastrite en fait ce n'était son estomac
était atteint d'hémorragie qui se sont
accentuées au fil des mois il s'est donc
avec ses pertes de sang et c'est petit à
petit anémiée ce qui l'a entraîné vers
la mort et en plus ces médecins qui
n'ont rien compris son mal lui en ont
administré du mercure qui était un
remède fort couru à l'époque mais le
mercure provoquer encore plus
d'hémorragie d'engrais 10 l'ont
précipité dans la mort car l'époque
hélas il fallait résister à la maladie
et aux médecins donc napoléon a été
vaincu par les deux est bon même s'il
serait mort quelques jours plus tard ou
quelques semaines voilà mon épaule et on
s'éteint le 5 mai 1821 sommes
pratiquement sommes à 17h44 et c'est à
17 heures sont à quelques minutes du
bicentaire exactes de sa mort 17h49 cinq
minutes et clément donc de cette maladie
de l'estomac qui ne pouvait pas être
soigné à l'époque une maladie de stress
napoléon est quelqu'un évidemment qu'ils
étaient quand même hyper actif qui a eu
des responsabilités que l'on sait qu' à
sainte hélène roy confinés dans cet
espace de l'ong hood a fini par tourner
en rond but en butte à l'hostilité
anglaise a développé comme ça c'est tu
sers encore plus et il est mort à ces
jeunes 51 ans finalement même pour
l'époque
pourquoi les anglais avait t-il décidé
d'envoyer napoléon à sainte-hélène
alors ils ont décidé à envoyer à
sainte-hélène parce que vont évidemment
cette île était beaucoup plus facile à
garder gars isolé de lointaines mais le
but caché syfy dire c'était de faire
oublier napoléon et là des anglais se
sont lourdement trompés parce que durant
la captivité on n'a cessé de parler de
napoléon et de sainte hélène et bien
entendu on en parle encore beaucoup plus
après sa mort donc c'est une défaite
anglaise terrible que cette bataille de
communication qu'ils ont perdu parce que
les anglais sont passés pour des
geôliers infâme
napoléon a réussi à mettre en scène et à
vivre quand même en partie un martyr et
bien eux sont passés pour les infâmes
bourreau donc a réussi à avoir si je
puis dire vivre et mettre en scène un
chemin de croix qui a comme ça à
accabler les anglais qui ont fini par
perdre la bataille plus importante celle
de la mémoire
si vous venez de nous rejoindre en
direct nous venons de vivre les
commémorations du bicentenaire de
napoléon 1er avec l'intervention des
manuels macron une première fois
l'institut de france avec un discours et
puis un dépôt de gerbes aux invalides où
il se trouve encore avec sa femme sur le
le peu rond sur le parvis des invalides
avec brigitte macron le voit à l'image
et puis du côté de thibault il aurait
qu'est notre envoyée spéciale devant les
invalides justement on voit les images
de thibault il aurait notre envoyé
spécial pour figaro live et on voit les
partisans de napoléon 1er avec les
drapeaux qui entonne la marseillaise
[Musique]
et on les entend
crier vive l'empereur pierre bras par
manuel vaqueront des envies de sacre
notre dame
on vient d'entendre les admirateurs de
napoléon 1er entonné la marseillaise
cette même marseillaise a été chantée
par quatre chanteurs du choeur de
l'armée française dans l'enceinte des
invalides
il y à oxyde us sur youtube qui
s'interroge pourquoi avoir chanté la
marseillaise plutôt que le chant du
départ pour l'hymne national en fait
parce que le chant du départ a été
préféré votre internaute a raison en
appelant à préférer le chant du départ à
la marseillaise d'ailleurs de jouer
presque plus la marseillaise sous l'
empire mais nous sommes nous ne sommes
plus sous l'empiré de la république
c'est la marseillaise donc très
logiquement de plus jouer les deux je
pense que pour une question d'emploi du
temps on a choisi la marseillaise qui
est tout à fait logique puisque c'est
nous sommes évidemment en république et
même si c'est le tombeau de napoléon
c'est une nécropole républicaine et une
république à laquelle napoléon à le
président de la république a également
rappelé fait partie puisque l' empire
dans une forme assez bizarre mais pour
pour nos contemporains était une forme
de la république en somme parce que ce
qui importe et c'était que la
souveraineté de napoléon 1er de l'an
pire émaner du peuple et c'est bien sous
leurs aînés du peuple issu de la
révolution française effectivement qui
s'est prolongée lors d'une manière à
laquelle on ne s'attendait pas mais
c'est effectivement sa souveraineté du
peuple et du peuple seul
ils n'ont plus une souveraineté sacré
comme l'était le roi de france
avec évidemment la religion une question
intéressante sur youtube toujours sur le
chat de figure en live sur youtube la
question de rome pl 1 mt qui a décidé de
l'enterrer dans cet édifice la
population n'est peut-être pas correct
mais non pour sa question
c'est louis philippe qui ont des îles
ont décidé de choisir les invalides pour
napoléon parce que louis philippe est
roi il n'est pas question qu'ils
ramènent un empereur
à paris en fait ils ramènent un chef de
guerre plutôt il ramène le personnage
napoléon avec d'ailleurs il est
accompagné de son petit chapeau et de
l'épée d'eau stérile donc c'est la
gloire militaire napoléon qu'il ramène
et qu'il installe aux invalides puisque
nous sommes dans le site militaire et
voilà dans cette église saint louis des
invalides et qui comme ça va commencer à
devenir une nécropole donc le choix de
huy phillips et d'inscrire napoléon
voilà dans la gloire militaire et non
pas amener un souverain puisque la
dynastie des bonaparte ne peut pas
exister puisque lui un étang roi roi des
français
c'est cette dynastie à lui celle d
orléans qui doit compter tout à l'heure
nous parlions de cette polémique qui
concerne cette oeuvre monumentale on va
dire contemporaine qui s'était qui
seraient exposés juste au dessus du
tombeau de l'empereur et pour qui les
historiens s'oppose farouchement et vous
disiez tout à l'heure que vous n'étiez
absolument pas d'accord avec la mise en
scène une installation de cette oeuvre
là il y à jean pointeau d'abord sur le
chat de figaro live il y a lancaster jc
qui nous dit c'est même insultants de
mettre un cheval au dessus de son
cavalier
là il se trouve que ce serait le
squelette du cheval préféré de napoléon
et puis jean pointeau sur le tchad
youtube du figaro qui nous dit que
risque monsieur le président emmanuel
macron interdire que le squelette soit
accroché à nouveau je ne sais pas quel
est l'avis de les manuels matheron sur
cette oeuvre qui serait amené à être
suspendu au dessus du tombeau mais alors
pourrait s'y opposer
oui évidemment puisqu'il est chef des
armées il pourrait tout à fait dire non
les choses on était peut-être trop loin
ils sont obligés de désavouer un certain
nombre de personnes a commencé par
certains membres de son gouvernement
peut-être des gens je ne suis pas hélas
dans le secret des dieux dans voilà dans
l' architecture de la décision mais
toujours est il que il faut qu'il se
méfie parce que ça lui sera reprochée
c'est lui le chef de l'état le chef des
armées et on retient l'image en 2005
jacques chirac avait fait l'impasse
totale sur le bicentenaire de la
bataille d'austerlitz par exemple avait
annulé une exposition aux invalides sur
la bataille bansky pas le cas pour
emmanuel macron puisqu'il ya une
exposition qui va rouvrir sur la mort de
napoléon aux invalides
jacques chirac avait envoyé par contre
au bicentenaire de la bataille de
trafalgar le porte avions charles de
gaulle
donc là l'image était désastreuse elle
est restée donc l'image de ce cheval
peut très bien rester et finalement
ternir abîmé un bicentenaire qui par
ailleurs a pris des allures puding
malgré des polémiques mais bon qui ont
été mises sur la place publique débattu
et sans trop d'excès je dois le dire
surtout par rapport à 2005 hante ces
questions étaient apparus plus vivement
et de manière plus caricatural donc
votre internaute précédent a tout à fait
raison c'est tout à fait insolite ans
les termes sont terme n'est pas excessif
du tout oui c'était lancaster jc 1 sur
le chat du figaro.fr qui faisait part de
deux sons de son commentaire sur ces
mêmes insultant de mettre un cheval au
dessus de son cavalier
on est toujours en direct depuis les
invalides la place vauban sur laquelle
se trouve notre envoyé spécial thibault
il aurait qui est en train de tourner
ces images de c'est
admirateur supporters de l'empereur avec
des drapeaux français qui ont entonné il
ya quelques minutes maintenant la
marseillaise qui viennent de faire une
minute de silence et qui viennent de
reprendre donc deschamps creed ils ne
sont pas tous d'ailleurs même uniforme
de la première guerre mondiale
donc il ya beaucoup aussi de d'amoureux
de la reconstitution aujourd'hui un qui
qui aiment se replonger dans l'histoire
pas seulement de napoléon peuvent être
l'histoire romaine l'histoire de la
première guerre mondiale
la deuxième guerre mondiale l'histoire
napoléonienne aussi comme ça revivent
les batailles les moments d'histoire et
après nos historiens parce qu'en fait
ils reconstituent les choses et nous les
avons en grandeur nature et bien entendu
en jouant tout cela on s'aperçoit voilà
de ce qui pouvait être possible nous ne
l'était pas aidé des contraintes
d'époque
donc ce sont toujours des enseignements
utiles en fait ils font un travail
d'historien en rejouant csn on a
toujours tendance un peu voilà le les
pas se moquer mettre toujours avoir un
moment à regarder
un petit peu sur eux mais néanmoins ils
font ça avec beaucoup beaucoup de
précision sait pas forcément ce qu'on a
à l'image mais il y a comme ça dans le
monde de reconstitution qui est vaste
qui s'étend aux états unis toute
l'europe
faut pas oublier que par exemple les
russes si je rejoue la bataille de la
boyne de borodino tous tous les mois de
septembre et avec des milliers de
personnes qui comme ça rien on file un
uniforme du napoléonien en fin de
l'époque napoléonienne qui
appréhendaient en parlait il ya quelques
minutes de sainte-hélène cette île
perdue de l'atlantique où les
britanniques avaient envoyé en exil
napoléon 1er après sa défaite sa
dernière défaite à waterloo
pourquoi les britanniques ne sont ils
pas exécutée alors les britanniques ne
l'ont pas exécuté parce que napoléon ont
représenté une figure politique qui
avaient un poids politique en france
assez important l'exécuter tu t'étais en
faire un martyr et provoquer des
troubles en france parce qu'on sait ce
qu'on craignait en tout cas il aurait
préféré que eh bien les français ils le
disent que les royalistes s'empare de
napoléon et le et le règle son cas si je
puis dire mais il pensait très bien que
il n'en serait pas capable donc ils sont
saisis de cette détention ils ont voulu
la la diriger eux-mêmes sans apport
extérieur et dans tous les droits
n'étaient pas acquis encore en
angleterre mais sommes quand même dans
la terre de l'habeas corpus l'exécution
sommaire
ça ne se fait pas en angleterre comme ça
pouvait se faire dans d'autres pays
d'europe donc du coup voilà ils
choisissent une solution si je puis dire
intermédiaire ils vont l'appeler général
bonaparte puis empereur et non pas
reconnaître son titre du tout même
ils vont l'emprisonner très loin mais
quand même lui accorder quelques
libertés sur il donc on est dans une
sorte d'entre deux politiques et en fait
qui est dirigé vers leurs opinions
publiques parce qu'il ya une opinion
publique anglaise très active les
journaux sont libres et ils craignent
l'opposition notamment libéral et ils ne
veulent pas être critiqué exagérément
donc il ya comme ça un souci de très
moderne d'ailleurs de retour d'opinion
publique et ils sont pour ça que les
anglais sont dans un entre deux parce
qu'ils ne sont plus dans un régime
absolutiste maison dans un régime qui
pas encore démocratique mais qui tient
compte de son opinion publique et
l'opinion publique anglaise à l'époque
est assez favorable à napoléon en
réalité leurs pires bande à tout à
l'heure quand on avait ces superbes
images à l'intérieur du dôme des
invalides au moment du dépôt de gerbe en
présence du chef de l'état emmanuel
macron envoyé ce tombeau de l'empereur
et vous parlez de la superposition de
plusieurs cercueils
et bien justement sur le chat du figaro
live sur youtube
sébastien roché merci sébastien pour
votre question la superposition de
plusieurs cercueils en différentes
matières at elle une signification
alors on avait voulu
à la fois préserver le corps et aussi à
sainte hélène non seulement il y avait
cinq cercueils en plus pour sur la dalle
il y avait trois dalles funéraires qui
qui comme ça condamné l'accès des le
tombeau on va dire qu'il n'avait pas
peur d'un retour de napoléon mais plutôt
de profanation où c'est plutôt une
question comme ça et à la fois de
dignité pour le corps aussi de de
conservation je les dis mais aussi voilà
de crainte de profanations dont qu'on a
on a essayé de préserver voilà 7 sept
tombes sont musulmans le plus possible à
sainte hélène
mais ensuite d'ailleurs on a parlé tout
à l'heure de de l'ascension en tout cas
c'était un des intervenants justement
sur cette place votre banque qui parlait
de l'ascension fulgurante de l'empereur
et c'est vrai qu'il a d'abord été
générale puis consul puis consul avis il
est finalement sacré empereur des
français en 1804 est-ce qu'on est trans
sacré empereur il voulait rétablir la
monarchie
alors il a voulu rétablir une monarchie
bien entendu mais la dynastie des
bonaparte une dynastie donc reposant et
émanant de la volonté du peuple c'est
comme ça qu'il a qui l'a qualifié
néanmoins au fur à mesure de l'avancée
lempire il copie de plus en plus les
bourbons il va jusqu'à se marier avec
une archiduchesse d'autriche qui est la
nièce de marie antoinette
donc on est une imitation de l'ancien
régime qui devient plus importante et
qui va
si je puis dire arrêté en partie son
aventure car le cette imitation ce
retour à l'ordre ancien et de moins en
moins compris effet de napoléon un
personnage qu'on n'arrive plus bien
définir et l' empire français et à ce
moment là enfin dans sa forme
comment ça va ressembler furieusement à
la monarchie 2014 donc cette cette
réapparition fait que voilà a pu trouver
mais napoléon a été entouré que de
monarques européens d'ancien régime
donc pour parler avec eux pour être avec
eux en fait il a voulu faire partie et
c'est sans doute là une de ses erreurs
et a voulu faire partie de leur cercle
la seule république existe elle était un
peu lointaine c'était celle des états
unis
donc dans cette europe monarchie qu'il a
voulu faire partie des grandes familles
qui en fait ne l'ont jamais accepté en
l'ont toujours combattu quand ils ont pu
et quand ils ont cédé face à lui parce
que il avait un sabre dans le dos et une
immense en fait ils n'ont jamais accepté
napoléon bonaparte
on est en train de voir et vous voyez
sur ces images le départ des supporters
admirateur de napoléon 1er dont on vient
d'assister aux commémorations du
bicentenaire de la mort en présence d'
emmanuel macron chef de l'état de sa
femme
emmanuel macron a d'abord pris la parole
à l'institut de france puis s'est rendu
sous le dôme des invalides déposé une
gerbe au pied du tombeau de l'empereur
les cérémonies sont désormais achevés on
le voit les gens s'éparpillent et vont
peut-être pour les plus fans d'entre
resté quelques minutes de plus vous
étiez très nombreux à nous suivre sur
figaro live et sur youtube je vous en
remercie on va peut-être poser une
dernière question et je vais prendre
celle de rome pl 1 mt qui vous demande
pierre brand a dont je rappelle que vous
êtes historien membre de
la fondation napoléon et vous répondez
depuis plusieurs et longues minutes
maintenant aux internautes du figaro il
vous interroge sur le fameux couvre chef
de napoléon bon d'où vient-il ce fameux
couvrechef qu'on voit sur la majorité on
le voit encore derrière des portraits
qu'on connaît et qui font partie de
notre imaginaire collectif et dans notre
histoire alors napoléon choisi ce
couvre-chef partir de 1802 à part on ne
connaît pas vraiment les motivations de
cette décision
néanmoins plus il avance plus il prend
la plupart du temps une apparence simple
parce qu'il veut se singulariser se
détacher de ses maréchaux et son
entourage qui est recouvert d'or et des
uniformes assez chamarré assez voyant
lui au contraire un petit peu à
l'imitation de frédéric ii le roi de
prusse à comme ça une apparence plus
simple et qui va rester une marque en
soit ce big horn va devenir le symbole
de napoléon et c'est là aussi son génie
de l'image c'est qu'il a construit comme
ça une silhouette tout à fait
reconnaissable et qui est devenu une
marque en elle même une marque déclinée
de mille et une façons
et c'est une volonté pour lui en fait
d'être reconnu
il savait aussi que l'apparition de son
personnage sur un champ de bataille et
bien effrayer ses ennemis là il a dit
cinquante mille hommes et moi ça fait
150 milles sur le champ de bataille donc
il a comme ça la volonté d'être aussi
charismatique jusqu'au bout et
d'impressionner par son apparence
finalement simple et c'est quelqu'un qui
comme ça à travailler on l'a dit tout à
l'heure sa communication dans les
moindres détails et ça on a fait ça en
fait partie
car napoléon a eu sept tenues
emblématiques qui l'a aussi rapproché de
ses hommes parce qu'avec cette apparence
simple il reste proche du peuple proche
d'eux
bach est proche des proches des gens en
adoptant cette news au colonel aurait
bientôt écouter pierre brand à d'autres
émissions et notre retransmission en
direct des commémorations du
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
s'achève peut-être un dernier mot je
vous laisse la parole pour pour finir qu
est ce qu on pourrait retenir de ces
commémorations qui était très attendu
qui suscitait polémique est vive
réaction en amont dès lors de leur venue
bah écoutez ils ont été assez
retentissant
quand même je dois dire gr grâce aux
médias grâce au public et un à paul et
moi on a fêté en continu d'être de faire
partie de nos aînés d'exister de comme
ça à travers lui l'histoire un quart ce
qui nous réunit beaucoup de français
c'est la passion de l'histoire du
patrimoine et donc c'est très heureux
que ces commémorations
et puis d'abord avoir lieu se soit
déroulé avec cette ampleur et ne pouvons
que nous en féliciter car notre histoire
est riche et nous pouvons encore merci
beaucoup qui reprend merci à vous ne
rien perdre de la fondation napoléon
d'avoir essayé à mes côtés cet après
midi pour commenter en direct les images
des commémorations du bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon 1er
je le rappelle nous avons assisté à la
prise de parole des manuels mâcon chef
de l'état à l'institut de france et s'en
est suivie aux invalides un dépôt de
gerbes au pied du tombeau de napoléon
1er on a pu suivre aussi à l'extérieur
des invalides grâce à notre envoyé
spécial
thibault il aurait ce qu'il se passait à
l'extérieur et en l'occurrence le
rassemblement d'un certain nombre de
soutiens à l'empereur et à napoléon 1er
et on le voit encore sur ces images
ils sont encore quelques-uns devant les
invalides à exprimer leur soutien aux
cris de vive l'empereur vive la france
voilà on va se quitter sur ces images
merci encore de nous avoir suivis merci
à tous pour vos commentaires et vos
questions à très vite sur figaro live
petit papa voici l'avis carré de ce mois
ci déguisé en dollars ne dit papa tu
vois si c'est pour rire
je comprends tout petits enfants au
clair aux tout petits enfants
tous les papas sont bons
angoisse le bois petite fille chérie que
consommer bien vite à mais son jeu
entraîne bien vite à la maison
cette médaille est celle de l'air